[Music]
It's
God. It's God.
It's God.
It depends like some a lot of them were
given the same mission. So did did
Muhammad claim that he's a messiah? M.
No. So he never claimed he was a
messiah. No. But he's the most vocal
voice in human history. I disagree.
Jesus is. No. No. He's the most vocal
voice in history that claim that the
Messiah will return. No, he's not. Who
else? What are you kidding? Jesus. No.
After Jesus,
Muhammad sallallam is the most vocal
voice. We said Jesus will return in the
end time. I disagree. No other human
voice. Paul
like Muhammad
prophecy. I don't Okay, let let me even
grant you that that's the case. We're
still not Wait, wait, hold on. We're
we're arguing over the identity of God.
Identity. Yes. So the identity of God is
the father according to the prophets. So
you're now limited to one identity. No,
I'm talking about what the prophet said.
Okay. So in our description, we have his
identity as I agree as what? Which is a
master
slave relationship. You've got a father
son relationship. Yes. It's a
relationship. It doesn't mean God is a
dad.
So you're saying that God is your
master. I'm saying that God is my
father. We don't believe in the same
God. I have a father at home. No, he's
saying because you said God is
transcendental. Is Jesus Is is Jesus? Is
Jesus and Moses and all of them wrong?
The same God that created Yeah. Are they
wrong when they say that God is our
father? I'm not going to get into if
they're wrong or right. You have to. No.
No. No. We're not going to get into
that. Why not? We're not going to get
into You have to. Look, look, let me
tell you why. Because you're saying that
I should become a Muslim. So you're
telling me that I should I should not
consider what the prophet said and I
should go to what Muhammad said instead
of what the prophet said. No, I'm saying
that in the Quran we have a relationship
of
a slave and a master.
So, so the prophets are wrong. My father
is also my father. I serve my father at
home. Yes. But he's also to a certain
degree my master. My dad tells me give
me a slap. Yes. You Yeah. A son can be a
servant to his parent, right? But he's
not merely a servant to his parent. So,
but in Islam, wait, wait, wait. In
Islam, God into an actual I didn't No, I
didn't do any of that. See, look. Let me
let me finish. Here's the difference.
The identity Allah Allah says that the
only thing that you could come to him as
is a servant, right? 1993. Chapter
19:93. So, you can be a servant of
Allah. You cannot come to him as a son.
Right? A literal son. No. Any son? No.
No. No. No. Cuz you're saying God is
literally a man. I never said that. So
don't don't do that. Christian theology.
No. In Christian theology, God is not
literally a man who had sex with a woman
and gave birth to Jesus. We don't
believe that. Okay. But you do believe
God is eternally beginning. Yes. So that
has nothing to do with sexual
intercourse. So what we have is God
eternity is transcendent. Transcending
what? That's it. God's reality. No, that
that you have to say what that means.
Transcending what? I'm not going to go
into theology. No. Oh my god.
Look, if you want me to become if you
want me to become a Muslim, you got to
break this stuff down. But the Muslim is
you have to accept the prophet as the
last prophet. But yeah, look, I
understand. If you if you want me No,
listen. If you want me to accept
Muhammad as a prophet and the Quran is
the word of God, the final prophet, you
got to tell me why. So, let's examine
the relationship of a father and son.
Can you have a father-son relationship
with Allah at all? Okay. If you have
what's the difference between a father
and son relationship and a master and a
slave? Very good. Jesus says this in
John chapter 8. He says that that that
the slave does not remain in the house
forever, but the son remains in the
house forever. And if the son sets you
free, you're free indeed. So there's a
different relationship when it comes to
slave and master versus son and father.
Okay.
A son is an heir. Like you you're the
heir of your father. Now we get into
lineage of the Messiah. Not necessarily
lineage, but relationship and the
identity of who the God is. When sons of
God, none of the none of the children of
Israel actually actually conceived this
idea that God was actually a father. I
understand this is my this is my
question. As a as a as a Muslim, can you
have a father son relationship with
Allah in any sense? So I have a
relationship. So you have a relationship
with God as your father. This is no I
do. Yes.
Can Can you Can I have this as a Muslim?
No, you won't serve God. No. Can I have
a father son relationship with more
obedient a son?
A son? No. Because God is more. Okay. So
the answer I got you. So the answer is
no. I cannot have a father-son
relationship with Allah in Islam. Right.
You could have a relationship. Your
actual but not a father and son. Right.
Okay. In the Quran, one of his names is
Brother, you're not answering my
question. He's not described as the
father, but one of his names is
described as you're not answering my yes
guardian and all that kind of stuff.
That's fine. Can I have as a Muslim?
Listen, listen to the question. Can I
have as a Muslim? It's yes or no. A
father and son relationship with Allah
from the Quran. You can have a
relationship as as a slave. Very good.
Very good. Okay. So, the only
relationship I can have with Allah is a
servant and a master relationship. Jesus
and the prophets taught that when it
comes to God, I can have a father and
son relationship. Arguing over a
semester, we're arguing over a theology.
And basically what what I'm saying is is
that the theology in Islam Let me
finish. Are we still serving God? Let me
finish. Let me finish. What I'm saying
is is that the theology of Islam does
not match the prophets. But you want me
to join a religion? Listen, listen,
listen. Because the theology does not
match Islam. I cannot go with Islam if
it contradicts the prophets. But you put
your own theology within your own. No, I
just I I just have what the prophets
say. We're arguing over We're arguing
over
it's okay. No, we're arguing theology.
If if your theology is not in line with
the prophets, look, here's my point. I'm
telling you, we're serving agree. You're
not You're not listening to me. You're
not listening to me. We both agreed God
is transcendental. We both agreed he's
gracious.
We both agreed God is transcendental and
God is gracious. Yes. Now we both agreed
that the God of Abraham is the same
source creator of everything. Correct?
Is the only source of of creator creator
who is not Allah. No, not Allah and
Islam. Allah is just a reality
transcendental reality. No, no. He's a
concept of a god that you have in Islam.
Something that's not real. It is real.
Concepts are real.
We're talking about a reality. Is is
Allah triune?
So that's what I'm saying. How the
prophets describe God, Islam is the
opposite. No, but the triune is only
works in creation. Triune doesn't work
outside. What are you talking about? God
is triune before creation exists. It's
not that's not in your scripture. It it
literally is in the scripture. You
interpret the scripture. No, that's what
the scripture says. You interpret it.
The area is not interpret. Okay. So,
look, so I can't I can't I can't be a
Muslim. Look, I can't be a Muslim and
excuse me, I can't be a Muslim and look,
I can't be a Muslim and have the same
theology of Jesus. If you look, my look,
this is my this is my substance. My
substance is what Jesus said. You're not
answering. No, I need you to pay
attention. My substance is the theology
of Jesus. Jesus says Jesus says that God
is our father. Jesus says that he is
God's begotten son. And so therefore
Islam says the opposite. So Islam is
false compared to in in line of Jesus.
So so is Jesus right or wrong? We're not
talking about who's right or wrong. We
are. You want me to become a Muslim
relationship. Is Jesus right or wrong?
Say you prefer relationship of a father
and son.
Okay. I got to end your child. It was
nice to meet you though, man. Y take
care. Be safe.
It's not real. It's not real.